[Music]
I think we have a really great panel
today we're going to go ahead and jump
into it and I'm going to let these guys
introduce themselves we'll get into
understanding what regenerative public
goods for sustainable communities
actually looks like cool so Kevin we can
start with you brother and you can go
ahead and introduce yourselves and you
guys go down and we'll take it from
there yep hey I'm Kevin Milwaukee I'm an
American software engineer and
entrepreneur I'm mostly known for
founding gitcoin which has funded about
$65 Million worth of public goods and
open source software in the ethereum
ecosystem all right uh David Casey here
I run a organization called funding the
commons uh we do conferences hackathons
and residencies exploring funding
mechanisms for public goods uh as well
as we've been starting to run funding
experiments um my name is Michelle
Bowens I'm the founder of the P2P
Foundation which is basically an
observatory of all things peer-to-peer
uh in this kind of origin I like to say
it's where Satoshi publishes white
paper um and may I don't look like it
but I'm in a sense a local because I've
lived in changai for 20 years now and
apparently the first person who tweeted
about Bitcoin yeah absolutely oh
nice cool so the first thing we want to
talk about is what actually are
regenerative public goods for
sustainable communities and this I think
this this conversation is really
important because one of the things we
haven't wrapped our head around at all
with parallel societies public goods in
general is first of all there's a
there's a governance concern there's a
there's a concern around how we govern
these communities and especially how we
get funding into these communities that
can be stable and regenerative and allow
these communities to grow over time so
this is really going to be a focus of
the discussion so let let these guys
take it from here what are regenerative
public goods for sustainable
communities yeah I mean uh for me the
easiest thing to do is take that word by
word uh so public goods are things that
are non-excludable and non- ralist
they're Goods that uh are hard to
produce and sell via a scarcity based
model like something you would get uh
when you purchase something on the
Internet because there are just things
that are available for free and they
can't be excluded so things like open
source software are public goods and
public goods can be a huge value add to
society but one of the problems that we
have in our economies is that it's
really hard to encourage entrepreneurs
to work on public goods because they
have no way to monetize them and so
that's the public goods part of the
phrase and then the the next word on
there is regenerative which to me just
means that the resource availability of
the system goes up over time as opposed
to a degenerative system which is
degenerating its public goods over time
so to me regenerative public goods just
means that you're getting more resource
availability of public goods like open
source software
cryptography and things of that nature
in your
ecosystem all right yeah I think he uh
basically encapsulated it uh I would add
that uh uh a regenerative public good uh
the way I look at it is a public good
that continues to regenerate and grow
itself over time or in other words
expand uh its capacity to do public good
and uh getting into the sustainable
communities piece
um when a funding stream is continuous
uh a community is able to plan over time
uh whereas if uh funding stream is kind
of one-off grants that a community is
struggling to reach for and continuing
uh to expend time and energy uh seeking
funding um then it becomes less
sustainable yeah guys when you talk
about this too it seems like there is a
an an asymmetry or a disconnect between
traditional funding models versus some
of the funding models that you guys are
discussing can you maybe elaborate on
that as well as like historically how
have these systems been funded or how
what does funding look like historically
yeah I mean I think that when you say
traditional funding models I think of
market-based funding models where uh I
pay you X and you give me Y and you get
some revenue from producing that good
and I get the good and you get a signal
that uh the market has demand for that
because I purchased that from you and
the problem with public goods is that
there's uh traditionally in in many
societies they've been provided by the
government
and the government you know as we all
know has a model where they collect
taxes from their citizens and then they
try to administer national public goods
things like National Defense
Transportation networks clean air clean
water things things like that um I feel
really unpopular talking about statism
uh at a crypto conference but um the one
thing I'll say here is that like I
Envision a two by two Matrix here of um
like public versus private Goods is the
xais and then uh is there Market signal
about what people are demanding or not
as the other axis and you can kind of
think of private Goods as like their
they private Goods uh which means
they're excludable and they rivalis and
you get a good s people entrepreneurs
get a good signal from the market of
what's available and what's not and then
the other quadrant is a public good
where someone in the government doesn't
really have a good sense uh as a central
producer or as a central power broker of
what the market is actually demanding
and uh so basically I think that the
Holy Grail of these system for me is to
produce public goods but to actually
have input a market feedback mechanism
to what public goods are in demand from
the body politic whether that's uh a
geographic body politic or a dow or or a
crypto ecosystems body politic for me
that's the Holy Grail is a public good
where there's actually signal and
intelligence and network of where to
provision public goods and to me
designing a good Capital allocation
mechanism for public goods is is solving
that problem is moving across that true
by Matrix of getting a public good
provisional system that also generates
signal yeah exactly and I would add in
in other words uh that the communities
at the Grassroots level are often um
most connected to the the needs and um
similar to Market signals it's uh how to
integrate uh the feedback from the
Grassroots um into the systems rather
than um prescribing or assuming
solutions from the top down which often
in the case of kind of nation states and
and more uh uh kind of hierarchically
structured systems uh with good
intentions fail because of a lack of
feedback signals and um in Kevin's
word's Market
signals yeah maybe I can give a bit of a
historical uh Arc so I think uh
basically empires have Commons which are
self local self-organized commun
communities which kind of like function
as a have a dampening effect uh on the
extractives of of the imperial system
then under capitalism basically the
commons are enclosed they tend to
disappear um and they're replaced by the
state so I think we should make a
difference between Common's goods and
public goods and public goods in my eyes
are defined as you know more linked to
the state and the problem with the state
public goods of course is that they
atomize people in consumers of of the
state of a state service so they kind of
tend to destroy the local
solidarity um and I think in this period
because of the the transnationality of
Finance the capacity of the State uh to
provide public good is weakening and so
we're looking for Alternatives and the
Alternatives might be what we are trying
to do which is
translocal uh funding of local common
goods uh and so that's kind of new that
we're trying to do this is to create a
new system to fund uh common goods right
and I think it's probably also worth uh
stressing
that uh public goods in my view need to
have some connection with nature with
material reality so you know like not
just coders that work uh separately uh
but is it really kind of rooted in the
material world are we regenerating
Material World I think that's an
important Criterium uh I like the
example of region Network right where
you have a planetary Ledger an
ecological State an ecological state is
a set of 36 metrics that reflect the
state of nature and so you always know
whether you degrading or regenerating
the environment in which you operate I
think that's a really interesting way to
look at it yeah so what I'm this is
really interesting what I'm hearing is
there's this more of an Ecology of grass
Roots based funding that's emerging both
in in potentially crypto and blockchain
but also just in the communities
themselves so it's like to use a term
that's been used before there's a a
crowdfunding sort of aspect to this as
well so we'll play on this a little bit
more and I'm curious about what have the
challenges around getting different
communities funded look like so Michelle
got into it a little bit but what go
ahead what would you see well I actually
did a study of uh 500 uh Urban Commons
projects in the city of gent in
2016 and actually typically it will be
two people that get a halftime wage from
an NGO and are working 16 hours a day so
they're totally under capitalized
underfunded and so my dream is of course
that while we are doing uh in web 3 and
I say we although I'm kind of an
outsider but anyway uh in the sense of
you know we creating This Global
coordination mechanism
[Music]
uh to trans locally coordinate labor and
the funding of that labor right but I
think we need to go down to productive
capacity some of the funding that we use
for ourselves I think should be directed
to the people who do resilient resilient
material production at a local level and
that will make them a lot stronger so
what I imagine uh and this is not
happening yet but you know just let's
use our imagination
is uh let's say we have the local
level and they create a cosmic Unity
right uh they have a Global Knowledge
and protocol Commons that can basically
help every node in that Network and then
maybe there's a translocal network of
ownership that owns a bit of the local
and the local owns a little of the
global and so you have this entanglement
between the local and the transnational
level and I think this is what we're
trying to do in a way that
what's new in history is that we are we
now have a technology for Trans local
self organization which I don't think we
had before and this is basically you
know changing the very nature of
civilization because civilization is a
geographic system that linked the urban
to the rural and now we're creating this
holy new layer on top of it and that's
the really challenge is how is that
going to work together and what the role
of the nation state sitting kind of in
the middle of of those two levels is it
going to continue to exist uh is it
going to destroy one or the other you
know there's many issues around that so
I'm going to let this is interesting I
want to play on this and I know that uh
David has some thoughts but I'm trying
to understand where the in the in your
in your trans local Vision in this
Grassroots Vision where is the actual
value being accured where is the the
funds actually coming from I don't know
I I'm not completely clear on that but I
think that as well we'll have some
thoughts on where it can come from from
a blockchain perspective but I'm curious
where you're well you know I I think the
the value can only come locally I mean
you need a surplus of the rural to
invest in the urban you need an a
surplus Urban workers to produce in the
cognitive layer so it you know it's it's
really labor and nature that creates
wealth and then we have created this
monetary
system uh that unfortunately doesn't
really reflect uh in a very good way
what's happening uh on the ground uh so
there's all a fictive and speculative
value that is not grounded in anything
real and especially now with this kind
of like high procreation of Fiat
money um and so I think the the good
news about crypto is that we now have
the capacity to create thermodynamically
informed currencies right as allo chain
says currencies seeing currents which
the current money doesn't see it you
know we suppose that we see it we can
actually not see what we do to Nature
and the essential problem of the
capitalist economy is externalization
right is that in order to be cheap and
competitive you basically push as much
as you can on the side and you don't see
the impact and in order to create a new
balance between nature and Humanity we
need to reintegrate that vision of
externalities and basically they have to
become internalities and I think the
technology we're building is a
technology that is able to do that
contribut accounting allows us to see
you know contributions that are not uh
doing for the working for the market
public goods funding is an example of
contributory accounting we recognize
that kind of work that the market
doesn't fund we can have flow accounting
you know 3D Accounting in an open
ecosystem and we can have thermodynamic
accounting which is actually seeing
flows of matter and energy and all these
technology exist today are experimented
with it's just that they're not
integrated yet and that's kind of the
challenge yeah playing off of uh seeing
currents I wanted to talk about um some
experience experiments we're running
with a partner organization in Africa
right now um using blockchainbased
public goods funding infrastructure uh
to fund projects in Refugee communities
and what we're finding is that when a
community uh propos is uh what the needs
are and proposes a budget for how to
resolve those needs um they can do it a
lot more cheaply than if a project is
kind of prescribed from an international
body and then uh you know contractors
are uh charging 300 400 500% um and the
funds are used much more inefficiently
and um doubling down on seeing the
currents uh we recently uh had the
privilege of observing in Action a
bitcoin-based uh multisig system that
saw the
donors uh the beneficiaries and
recipients all the contractors uh
vendors and uh stakeholders and
community members colle collectively
observing the multisig where the
payments were going how the funds were
being spent and this uh kind of
transparent uh system for public goods
fing funding infrastructure which which
blockchain are particularly well enabled
for um is a I think a really really
interesting tool that we're just
starting to see um how how much more
efficient we can use uh funding at the
Grassroots level absolutely and Kevin
you have a lot of experience at gitcoin
with thinking about the way that these
funding mechanisms can actually work and
what they look like so maybe I know
you've talked a lot about quadratic
funding and its implementation can you
maybe speak to that with relation to
what these guys are saying how is that
relevant yeah sure um okay so quadratic
funding is a way a mechanism for funding
public goods and it's been the primary
mechanism behind getcoin over the last
four years we are going multi mechanism
we're starting to do retroactive funding
and guilds and conviction voting and a
bunch of other mechanisms but uh we have
done a lot of quadratic funding we've
done uh $65 Million worth of quadratic
funding over uh 5 million transactions
to about 5,000 different grantees and
basically we're putting this into
practice and before I tell tell you what
it is I just want to say that Glenn W
and vitalic boin and Zoe hittig are the
ones who invented this mechanism I did
not invent this mechanism I'm just
putting it into practice but basically
the way it works is that you put
together a matching pool and you let
grants or just projects people who are
doing stuff in the community apply to be
a part of a matching round and then
contributions to those grants are
matched for during the round usually a
two-e period contributions to those
grants are matched by contributions from
the matching pool but there's one weird
trick that makes it work and that's that
the grants matching the amount that they
get is M based more on the number of
contributions than they get more so than
the amount that was funded and so if you
raise $100 from 100 contributors and I
raise $100 from one contributor you're
going to get 99% of the matching pool
because that's how the math Works in
quadratic funding tldr the opinions of
the rich and the few matter less than
the poor and the many so we're
democratizing the allocation decision
from a central power broker who's up in
their Ivory Tower figuring out how to
fund public goods to something that
actually creates a signal in the market
of what does the body politic actually
care about Within These ecosystems and
so that's really the the cool idea is to
democratize the funding decision and to
create a market signal for what people
actually care about but there's two
Achilles heels with quadratic funding
the first is the Cil and collusion
problem basically if I'm going to deploy
that $100 to my project why don't I just
make up a 100 different identities and
make it seem like my project is bro
broadly popular so um uh and then
another flavor of that problem is that
could bribe all hundred of you to
contribute to my project to get uh to
drain the matching pool so those are
solvable problems I can get into how
getcoin has approached that through the
22 rounds that we've run and that's the
Achilles heel number one of quadratic
funding the second Achilles heel is how
do you top up the matching pool um we
have been really lucky at getcoin to get
early support from the ethereum
foundation from uh vitalic from nft
projects and projects that contributed
to the matching pool and we got a large
donation of uh dog coins uh back in 2021
that um we now have a $20 million
matching pool and so if we do a million
dollars per quarter we're funded for the
next 20 quarters and so um very
privilege to to to have made a lot of
progress on those two Achilles heels of
quadratic funding but you know for a
project like logos or any other project
that has a treasury largely of its own
tokens one of the really natural things
you can do is you can deploy your own
currency to the matching pool and that's
a great way to administer public goods
in your ecosystem it's not the only way
to administer public goods in your
ecosystem but I think of it as one tool
in the toolbox there's other tools out
there as well but quadratic funding is
just one of these constructions that can
work really well and uh I think it's
been proven out somewhat in the ethereum
community I can't tell you how happy I
am that you mentioned logos just
now so well it gets me thinking this is
really vital and critical for just what
what we're doing at logos right we have
a suite of technologies that are all
public goods right or common goods to
use Michelle's eloquent term so thinking
about funding for parallel societies and
parallel networks which is largely at
least in the digital space common goods
so what is what does that look like for
you guys for parallel societies for
funding parallel societies what's that
look like and what's the future of it
look
like so I'm going to um te this one up
for Michelle and see what you have to
say about it uh well yes okay uh so I
think what's new is this kind of Link
direct link within the local and the
trans
logo um and I also think we are moving
to a new value regime like every Big
societal Revolution is a value is a
value regime change right um like in
feudal times we believe the value came
from the land and then uh after the 16th
century we believe that value came from
labor in the
market um and I think that what we are
finding now is that that value is
contributory right so if value is only a
commodity that comes from scarcity then
you have to push everything nons scares
out of the way and this is what we did
for four centuries and nature doesn't
look in a very good State because of it
so we need to reintegrate the notion of
contribution and I think this is uh very
important because um you know this is a
weird uh kind of tunnel I'm making but I
I'm reading this thesis about how the
early Christian monastics revolutionized
the notion of work because for the
Romans and the Greeks work was for the
slaves and they said no no at laa work
and pray so work became something that
was really valuable you know way of
basically uh putting the Divine in the
world and making the world a better
place but in the 16th century we made
labor into a commodity again so labor
became empty and you have to find a job
to survive and that's not necessarily a
meaningful job right it's you you just
need a money to survive and to eat but
look at what we are doing we creating
open ecosystems where we can see what
everybody's doing and then we can freely
associate our passionate skills to a
common project so this is a this is a
revolution in how we see labor right so
here's then the thing is that I think
that we do that locally and translocally
at the same
time and that means that a portion of
our value can go to the trans local to
strengthen the local and that's what I
call the cosmo local right so everything
heavy is local and everything light is
global and shared and so let just said
this thing so it's about regulation of
society right so the Empire controls the
market uh and the commons still exist in
capitalism the commons are enclosed and
the state regulates the market then the
market
escapes from the state because it's
transnational and it's no longer
regulated and that's why for 40 years
people feel powerless because it doesn't
matter who you vote for you can't change
it at the national level and what it
means is in my view we have to inflate
the commment right because otherwise we
have to inflate the state again that
would mean a world government I don't
think that's a good idea but if we
inflate common institutions then we have
a counterpower to Trans financial
Capital right and look at what we do
with capital we actually turn Capital
into
contribution right we talk about
quadratic fending we we say yeah it's
good to have Capital we use it to fund
public goods so we turn it we turn
Capital into Commons
infrastructure and then we we have a
voting
mechanism which recognizes the the
contribution of capital with we or at
the same time we limit it right uh
through this quadratic voting system so
I I think we're doing a lot of good
things in web 3 uh which in a way if you
want to look historically you should
have look at at Medieval cities you know
run by the guilds in association with
their own legisl legislative systems a
very dis the system of
power and I'm pretty sure this is where
we're
going um building on the cosmo local
analogy um we just ran a month-long uh
open source developer residency over in
changai um and it was an interesting mix
of the global and the local um bringing
in kind of experimental public goods
funding mechanisms um bringing in local
developers and local and Regional Nos
and Building Solutions together um here
for the Southeast Asian context um and
then some of which are applicable
globally um and leveraging open source
technology we're we're basically
building in the open um and so that's an
ongoing experiment we're getting into um
and I wanted to go back to something you
said about kind of value systems and how
we measure value and um accounting
systems and and what the regen network
has been doing um and I just wanted to
give you guys an analogy of how broken I
think our accounting system is um so
this is a example from an economist
named Herman Dy ecological Economist um
who also had a background in biology and
um he gives the example of coal mining
so when you blow up a mountain to
extract coal um there's like basically a
series of GDP plus signs there's no
minus signs so the first one is the coal
itself so that's um economic growth
value created um you know coal miners
are working hard um there's explosives
that are going off more economic growth
uh you know the production and
deployment of those explosives um then
there's the river that has to be cleaned
up by the um kind of debris over the
explosions um and so the the kind of
state hires people to go clean up the
river and that's also economic growth
GDP job creation um and then there's the
coal miners themselves who have this
thing called black lung disease and it's
pretty pretty pretty bad thing and they
have to go to the hospital and uh then
the doctors have more work so that's
also economic growth and like there's no
um accounting for for nature and and
human health in this equation and that's
kind of like what our models are
today can I give an example uh I I'd
like to use when I my lectures so it's
the three nurses so the first nurse is a
Catholic nurse she's she's not getting
paid she's healing people but she's
neutral for GDP then you have a public
Hospital doing the same job paid by the
government she's negative for GDP she's
a cost and then you have a private nurse
working in a private hospital and she's
growing GDP positively so in a commodity
regime you have these three nurses doing
the same job and they judge entirely
differently if you have a contributory
regime they're all doing the same job
they all recognize for the value they've
for healing people whether they work in
a private public or you know religious
sector right so this is basically just
to enhance your your analogy that the
system that we have now doesn't work
because we we completely ignore negative
social and ecological externalities we
just don't count them we don't we don't
see
them yeah this is a really beautiful
conversation and something that's close
to my heart because what you're getting
at is ultimately like game theoretic
scenarios where everything is a race to
the bottom or an arms race or we we
would call a malakan dynamic where
people trying to optimize for their
short-term benefits at the expense of
collective well-being and that's an
absolutely horrible scenario to be in so
uh how can we continue to rectify these
these problems with funding with sorry I
think about Kevin a lot and his idea of
quadratic funding but there's other
funding mechanisms potentially we could
apply to parallel societies that might
be beneficial to get outside of these
Dynamics as well yeah um
uh yeah just one reaction quic funding
is not my idea it's vitalic GLS I'm just
yeah I just meant you're like your
promotional idea part part of the
movement yeah um you know I think
that at some level a lot of these things
can be stated as coordination failures
uh a coordination failure is anytime you
have a group of humans that want to
create X outcome but they can't
articulate that outcome or they can't
find ways to coordinate their resources
in order to acheve that outcome and one
of the things I think that's really cool
about blockchains is that they're kind
of the stateful internet they're
programmable and so you can build these
little circuits that help people
coordinate uh around their shared needs
and and ideally solve uh coordination
failures where uh basically each of the
agents in the system can have more
confidence that each of the other agents
are going to converge on solving that
issue and so that's getting into the
realm of mechanism design how do we
build systems that create credible
commitments that we're going to solve
shared problems together in the most
generalized sense and one of the things
that I've sort of stumbled upon since
founding gitcoin is just that there's
really uh dozens of really cool Capital
allocation mechanisms coordination
mechanisms out there that can be used to
help fund our shared needs or or
coordinate towards uh solving these
problems and um you know they range they
range from
things that were developed uh eons ago
during when we were hunter gatherers how
do we coordinate our resource allocation
to The Agrarian to the industrial
information age and now I call this era
the onchain era there's a certain amount
of mechanisms that only could exist now
that we have blockchains and uh I
recently wrote a book called the onchain
capital allocation handbook which sounds
like a mouthful but just just Capital
allocation it's just spending resources
and and uh doing it on chain so I wrote
a book called Beyond chain Capital
allocation handbook and uh went through
uh a couple dozen of these different
mechanisms and I'm just trying to spread
awareness of of of what's available out
there in order to solve these problems
and I'd say that there's sort of like a
primordial soup of mechanism designers
and experimentation and people deploying
Capital uh and trying to figure out
which of these mechanisms are going to
scale and become the backbone of capital
Flows In These parallel Societies in the
future but it's it's the first inning
it's the first quarter in terms of
actually bearing these out in in in
progress and so I'm really curious to
see what happens over the next couple
years in exploring this design space and
I think that you know I have uh a ton of
access as the founder of getcoin to a
lot of these big brains and my job in
writing the book is just democratizing
that access so you can get a copy of the
book at Alo book. gitcoin doco um a
book. gitcoin doco and uh if you're not
someone who reads all that much there's
a GPT that's read the book that you can
chat with about these ideas and that's
kind of a fun way of exploring the
design space as
well nice so let's throw a little bit of
a wrench in the gears I think in
thinking about this if we were talking
to a state-based bureaucrat or a
politician they may say well we have
solutions for a lot of these problems
that you guys are going to face and we
call it
ESG and environmental sustainable
governance models that the corporate and
the Legacy system architectures have
started to embrace and is a really
popular so why why will that not work or
why is that not working and how is what
we're going to do
better um I'll take this first so uh I
believe that in the kind of process of
industrialization we we now have these
complex societies where uh the decision
makers and capital allocators are so
disconnected from the grass roots that
we don't really or or let's say these
decision makers don't have a direct uh
feedback loop and they they don't maybe
they're well-intentioned um but it's
difficult for them to have visibility on
the ground and maybe these kind of
Grassroots Community networks uh aren't
Incorporated and aren't the the feedback
isn't coming back into the system and so
the my counter would be um how can we
enable these kind of democratic and
experimental allocation systems and uh
encourage these like larger funding
bodies to start running Pilots that
enable and Empower uh the Grassroots and
the people that are actually connected
to the ground connected to community
needs um connected to the Earth
connected to Nature feeling the direct
results of the tragedy of the commons
and and letting them do that allocation
work yeah this reminds me of Michelle
yeah he's already laugh okay we had a
little bit of a discussion before this
panel and he said in in the scenario you
envision it there there is no tragedy of
the commons there can't be in this in
this case right so uh you know the this
famous actually the most read scientific
article in the history of the world
right uh G hardin's tragedy of the
commons I belong to those people who say
it doesn't exist but let me explain why
because he's not talking about the
comment he's talking about Open Access
resources that have no rules and the
commons are defined through
self-regulation
so that's where it gots it completely
wrong so in the lat in Latin you have R
nus what belongs to no one and R
communes what belongs to a community the
commons belong to a community that
self-organizes the protection of its
resources and you know you go uh you
look at satellite image of the world and
ask yourself where is it green as very
easy Austria Switzerland Japan because
their Mountain flanks are commons and
these communities have Protected Their
own you know natural environment for
Generations right so the tragedy of the
commons is non-g governed nonprotected
resources that are for everyone and then
obviously selfishness will play its role
and will deplete it so we should call
the tragedy of the commons the tragedy
of the
non-common or even maybe the tragedy of
the market because actually what's
happening is that people are then
selfishly using these uh common
resources and selling them on the market
so it's it's a very misleading uh theory
in my
view yeah and something I'm thinking
about that with these these funding
mechanisms I I think a lot about how
they can actually alter and
change our communities as we move
forward parallel societies Network
States whatever the community is somehow
it seems like the funding mechanisms
themselves have the ability to alter the
Dynamics that allow those communities to
thrive and so is that how you guys also
Envision that you see the the Dynamics
of funding itself changing communities
on a fundamental
level yeah I mean I I think that the
word that comes to mind here as we're
describing this is the word institution
which is something that's that's sort of
like something that's rigid and hard and
can be depended upon for achieving a
certain set of uh outcomes in the
Industrial Age our institutions are
these uh at least in the west there are
these sort of like giant marble
buildings that uh you walk into and
they're sort of majestic and uh things
like courts things like Banks things
like the local government and there
where decisions are made that are
existential in in creating culture and
you know exits which are the things that
are outside of the institutions things
that are soft things like culture things
like the relationship things like the
Arts uh a lot of the things we hold near
and dear uh I would describe as exti
tutions so inst institions hard rigid
can be depended upon and exti tutions
are the human culture and the society
that have been built around them and
they're just an inversion of each other
and now that we're going on chain we can
create digital hardness and programmable
money and programmable institutions and
so we're building these Capital
allocation networks that uh since we can
program our values into our money really
the design space is more or less
infinite and we can decide what those
things look like but you know the world
I want to live in is having solid
infrastructure rure and funding the Arts
and funding The Commons in addition to
all the great for-profit things that are
out there as well and um you know so I
think there's an opportunity to uh
support people who are creating exti
tutions that are regenerative in culture
and arts and um and and all the other
things that we hold dear in our in our
families and in our communities and the
institutions in the Industrial Age were
these uh physical meat space things and
now the institutions can be onchain
institutions and the institution inform
the exti tutions and and vice versa so
there's sort of an EB and flow there and
it's really beautiful design space I
mean we can program our values into our
money it's really profound and I hope
that we explore the design space and and
um and and create something really
meaningful yeah go ahead David yeah I
wanted to add um how kind of I've seen
funding flows shape uh communities and
projects so it's really common in the
nonprofit world for an organization to
receive a gr
um use that Grant to do a project and
then uh maybe even scale up because
they've been told that they're going to
get followon funding if they succeed in
XYZ and then it doesn't come through and
then they've basically uh scaled up
increased their burn rate and um they
have to lay people off or cancel the
project and then they have less Trust of
of funders in the future and uh this is
kind of like something that I've seen
shape uh the the nonprofit space um and
and to cite an example I see some octant
folks in the audience um experimenting
with combining uh kind of traditional
endowment models with quadratic funding
and Democratic Community participation
um to enable kind of like continuous
funding flows using a kind of uh non
depletive treasury um and I wonder like
uh it' be fun to sync about like like if
logos is thinking about these things and
um you guys have spoken with octen I'm
sure
yeah um I don't know if well what it
you're what I'm thinking about now is
actually I'm going to venture off the
reservation a little bit in the sense
that if somebody here in the audience
they're building a some public good
infrastructure like we're doing at logos
like you guys touched on it but maybe
they're really confused how do they
actually plug into these these funding
ecosystems like how do can they get
funding quick efficiently in a way that
is sustainable and meets their
community's needs in the way that we're
talking about so how can they get
involved and get funded like
ASAP yeah I mean like gitcoin is
generally the the first place I send
people to yeah that's going be my answer
too use
getcoin I no I I'm I'm ship hosting
there's a bunch of really great uh
experiments uh I'm I'm familiar more
with the ethereum ecosystem but optimism
retr funding getcoin octant there's some
stuff in arbitrum that's it's really
mature and so there's a there's a
plurality of different options out there
and um you know I know that's annoying
that there's not just one of them but uh
actually the plurality is a feature
because it creates
antifragility in it creates a diversity
in different funding mechanisms and
implementations and that's actually
really important because if one of them
goes away then you still have all of the
others so uh the answer is that there's
many places that you can go in the
ethereum ecosystem um and I'm sure that
as logos and other blockchains grow
they'll also have a plurality of funding
mechanisms as
well nice okay I think we have a little
over eight minutes left and I think
maybe right now is a good time to take a
couple of questions but give it a round
of applause for these guys this is an
amazing amazing
[Applause]
discussion this is like the super heady
Giga Brain
Trust hardcore guys that thank you so
much so if you guys I guess we can line
up now for questions right how does that
work somebody yeah there's a mic in the
middle there mic in the middle step up
to that
yeah um I think the most effective way
to fund Rising is like launch MIM coin
but but MIM coin just for the Traders so
if we can like launch a token for
Builders like uh your contribution and
your uh maybe your skills contributed to
this smart contract and then you can get
that coin maybe would be great way I'm
not sure because in past I worked for a
doll for a long time and actually I host
lots of like um online event online uh
Workshop there are lots of people they
can use them spare time to coordinate
with each other and can make some very
useful thing but the the most
challenging for them is like fing uh is
uh related with uh funding a location I
mean before before funding coming they
can uh coordinate with each other very
very good but after funding coming I
mean if they have the fee um the
coordination the coordination way will
be the very very hard so is there any
like very easy way to like cooperation
with each other so like launch token for
Builders Builder um building as exchange
for token how about this
idea so you're just to make sure we're
clear on the question so it's about how
do we how do we cooperate if you're like
a community or group and you want to
cooperate to get funding how would you
go about it is that is that what you're
getting at because I only got yeah parts
of your question sorry yeah yeah yeah is
my question is that
um I mean for tra us how to like uh
coordination with them launch a MIM coin
if you believe you just B it so like for
Builders if you want to uh cooperation
with each other more efficient if you
believe you just build it and then you
can get some like uh token back and then
in future that would be more like uh
utility I'm not sure I mean just like
longterm token for Builders
as easy as launch M coin ah mcoin
yeah um I could share a few existing
examples that I've seen that kind of
touch parts of it so one is the uh
Talent protocol um which enables onchain
kind of skill recognition attestation of
Builders um which in the future could
enable let's say uh airdrops and retro
payouts to builders that have
contributed um another one is the
protocol Guild which is an ethereum uh
kind of developer uh Guild that uh
receives not just eth at this point but
a number of other tokens from uh layer 2
ecosystems that are dependent on the
ethereum layer one um for their
continuous functionality so that's like
a way that um various ecosystems are
rewarding uh public goods
Builders um had another one but it's
kept my
mind can I give the example of a
Grassroots economics maybe because I
think that's such an exemplary uh
project so so okay I may have some
things wrong but uh bear with me so
basically in Kenya like in many other
worlds in many other countries in the
global South we have these rotational
Savings and Loans associat basically
usually groups of women who put some
money every month or every week and then
there every week or every month somebody
member gets the whole pot right and so
that allows you to buy a mobile phone a
fridge something that poor people
normally cannot access um so they asked
1,000 of these 4,000 groups to give uh
some money for common fund as collateral
and build a Mutual Credit on top of it
although Will Ric says it's not Mutual
Credit so I'm not sure how to call it
but it looks like mutal credit and so
basically you you know you introduce
like U uh multiplier effect so you have
20% money and you have 80% of this
credit currency right so suddenly you
have times for what you had he put a
blockchain on it to make it transparent
and they discovered they have like a
six-fold accelerator so now people can
fund you know this project and they know
that their investment will go six times
uh
bigger uh then he introduced something
called Ostrom contracts so instead of
individual smart contracts they are
collective contracts commitment pooling
and uh now he's doing this cyber
physicalization of ancient sharing
practices so it's basically talking with
Elders how they used to do you know
commoning and gifting in their
communities and try to scale it uh to
the systems I think that's fantastic
because that's really rooted in real
people doing real things and using the
blockchain to kind of augment and scale
up what they're already doing uh so that
I think that's a perfect example of you
know improving coordination and using
the blockchain in a very very smart way
you know to just put more grease uh in
in what in these Dynamics thank you one
more question and very quick question
and answer and then we're we're out so
Kevin all this incredible hard work
you've been
doing
yet the majority of your pool was funded
by a
dogcoin how does that make you
feel
incredible
um uh so there's a $20 million matching
pool uh for gitcoin
and
um I don't have the numbers off the top
of my head but it's been multiple
million dollars of generous donations
from defy projects and nft projects in
the 2019 and 2020 cycle
uh and then we also had an nft launch in
2020 that was uh called the moonshot
Bots and that raised $3 million and then
the dog coins were like $4 million and
then it's appreciated from there so it's
actually only like a fourth dog coins
but uh we live in a world where you can
fund public goods with dog coins well
that's kind of what I'm getting at is
you know in a sideways way like what is
the role of these kind of mimetic tokens
and this value creation out of thin air
going into public goods where do you see
the funneling of that into more public
good retener sorry guys 20 seconds yeah
uh I mean dog whff hat has a 100x more
valuation than getcoin so clearly you're
asking the wrong guy but it seems like
there's something there and I know the
latest meta is AI meme coins so uh you
know maybe someone who's involved in
that scene can can say what it is but uh
the other thing that I'll mention is the
regen token which seems to be doing good
stuff with with meme coins or they call
them culture coins so there's a design
space thing doing it ethically and doing
it well is not something I know about
though cool thank you so much guys get a
give them a round of applause this was
an amazing panel thanks Sterling oh no
problem
[Music]